vivre auprès du vin
c'est bien dans ma vie mais de quel vin
ce geste il l'autre jour émile mon
beau-fils qui fait d'école de commerce
te dit tu sais pas tu maintenant on ne
crie pas les boîtes à l'époque on crée
des start up
bon jusque là je suis vieux modèle mais
j'arrive à suivre un cours mais quand il
poursuit et qui me me dire ok on crée
même des start-up éphémère des start-up
éphémère là je suis resté un peu pantois
une touche start up en anglais sa
traduction française c'est bien démarré
débutée on démarre quelque chose qui
doit s'arrêter de suite je pense qu'on
des filles un peu là les aventures comme
l'internât pour on attend qu'il pousse
qui s'étoffe et qu'ils fassent des
fruits et on les récolte c'est pareil
devront enfin l'enfant quand le faire
voler du conte l'élève plus tard il
vient d'une petite travail
il fait des fruits aussi mais une
start-up éphémère qu'est ce qu'elle
produit qu'est ce qui se passe pendant
ce très court temps de vie mais bon je
vous dirai ce que j'en passe je pense
que l'intérêt c'est que du vin du vin
dans une tempête des tablettes et des
bourrasques de vent je pense que
d'autres appellent russe a du fric et du
profit moi je suis saulnier ont métier
c'est de faire du sel chez nous là notre
métier le vent comme on l'utilisé on
essaye de l'apprivoiser on en a besoin
pour faire du sel apprivoiser levant ce
peu difficile dit ça veut dire quoi
apprivoiser demande le petit prince
renard apprivoisé
tu vois si nous apprivoisons puis sera
indispensable ma vie est unique au monde
pour moi et moi je serai indispensable à
ta vie est unique au monde pour toi si
je me permets de reprendre quelques mots
de cet exil et ici c'est que pour pour
moi l'entreprise
c'est avant tout créer du lien créé des
biens créer une ambiance de vie chez
nous les sauniers sais c'est faire du
sel fair du sel c'est notre salaire et
pour faire du sel on a besoin sur nos
salaires de deux pompes et des liens en
créole et nous traitons la fibrose et
tous les jours dame nature
tous les jours nous faisons équilibre
entre le soleil la pluie le vin tous les
jours nous mêmes nous allions terre mer
et ciel pour créer ce produit qui est
unique au monde qui est unique
nécessaire l'humanité
moi dans ma famille on et saunier de
père en fils notre métier c'est de faire
du sel avons peur qu'ils ont intérêt on
n'avait pas la notion d'entreprise et la
notion d'entreprise dans le sens du
terme latin qui est interprété ray
saisir avait la main nous avons
travaillé bernard quelques centaines
l'année dans ce métier l'action cumulée
tout le monde mais un jour là l'aude
tout s'est écroulé pour nous et sonia
delaunay
nos patrons je parle bien de patrons par
l'entrepreneur nos patrons trouvé que le
vent ne soufflait plus chez nous que le
soleil ne brille est plus que la mer
était aux douces et donc saison d'aller
par d'heure par delà les mers et les
montagnes chercher ceux celles qui pour
eux avaient valeur de blanc mais qui
pour nom des sauniers est elle celle de
la vie et alors que pour moi la mère
avait un goût de plus en plus à l'est le
vam arracher le chapeau et j'ai revu le
soleil brille et je me suis rapproché de
mes compagnons d'infortuné laissés sur
ses terres qui allait devenir des
friches inculte
j'ai pris mon bâton de pèlerin je suis
allé chercher d'autres compagnons qui
qui avait les compétences que je n'avais
pas et nous sommes partis dans l'
aventure pour moi le plus gros du
travail reste à faire apprendre un
nouveau métier
le métier d'entrepreneur celui qui
saisit avait la main et qui reprend l
ouvrage avait force devant et nous avons
sur le littoral audois qui nous est si
cher remis notre ouvrage sur les deux
sites
sa lignée de l'aude le cndd russa au
pied du massif de la clape fait 400
hectares et le salen de la palme qui est
un peu plus au sud sur le au pied de la
falaise de la franqui ou deux
au pied du canigou nous avons pu
remettre ses sites en production
repomper de l'eau refaire un autre
métier et alors les oiseaux sont revenus
sont arrivés sur le site pas si on avait
de l'eau c'est une des rares activités
l'activité salir qui préserve et gérant
général environnement nous et on a revu
scintiller le soleil le soleil le sel
pour un lapsus révélateur pour moi c'est
le soyez d'avis donc le sel sur ses
terres blanches et reprendre notre
métier mais ce n'est pas tout autour de
ce sel il ya des valeurs humaines et on
a su re développer en même temps que la
production de sel et les productions
agricoles comme l'est la production
strictes puisque ont produit des huîtres
aussi sur les salaires
alliant restructurer une partie de l'île
des sites demain au froid des alv
peut-être mais on a reçu on assure m et
mettre en avant les valeurs de la table
aussi l'art de la table au travers d'un
restaurant bar à vin boutiques et valeur
muséographique puisqu'on a buzzé où on
reprend voile et les haïtiens soignés
mais même les souliers d'aujourd'hui la
lézarde visuel aussi il photographe et
peintre se régale de venir croquer ou
saisir les images de ces sites et les et
nous les exposons sur le site aussi et
en même temps on a remis aussi l'arc du
bien vivre ensemble autour de fêtes de
fête du sel où nous avons des les
enfants qui nous accompagnent et les
sauniers qui ont le bonheur de pouvoir
offrir une fois par an
le sel en pause pour qu'on vive
tout ça s'est développé petit à petit
pour le plaisir de tout le monde
je dirais que c'est une nous avons mis
en place ici mais l'exemple de deux
civilisations durable voilà et
aujourd'hui nous avons aussi ouvert un
nouveau chapitre sur ses développements
parce que toutes les idées même les plus
depuis les gérer comme peuple puisse
avoir pour son tout regarder et donc
nous avons cette année mis en place sur
le canal sur le canal latéral de vitesse
ou où nous avons pu fédérer autour de ce
projet les meilleurs du monde qui sont
venus pour essayer de battre leur propre
record
le venture planche à voile et nous avons
eu cette année les bat des records
nationaux qui ont déjà été battus le la
palme speed challenge
il ya un petit c'est un garçon qui
accueille zaki et sur une planche à
voile
il est assez intéressant parce que il ya
quelques années vous auriez pu le voir
sur la fête du sel de gruissan en train
d'offrir un peu de sel
c'est le fils d'un de mes compagnons
d'infortuné par eric c'est marvin qui la
feront les 49 sur l'eau que son père a
pompé en méditerranée vaut faire du sel
je dirais que la boucle vous couperez on
a redonné vie à un site avec toutes les
activités différentes qu'on peut on peut
imaginer je pense qu'encore un endroit
on a du chemin à faire
voilà donc voudrait bien compris
d'entreprise
nous les sauniers nous ne jugeons pas à
hauteur de sa rentabilité financière
pouvoir que g faille mais plutôt à la
hauteur de sa rade de sa production
humaine et des besoins que là qu'elle
peut combler sur une vision globale de
territoire merci
[Applaudissements]